Cette mission est simple et rapide.
Agent Valérian, vous agirez seul.
Je bosse qu'avec ma coéquipière.
- Salut !
- En tandem.
On se tire !
Vous avez quasiment 20 minutes de retard.
- Ouais, le temps passe vite quand on s'amuse.
Bienvenue sur Alpha.
La cité des mille planètes.
Où pendant des centaines d'années, toutes les espèces ont partagé leurs connaissances
et leur intelligence en harmonie.
Un vrai paradis.
C'est pas croyable.
Après des siècles de paix, de prospérité,
une force inconnue veut détruire tout ce que nous avons créé.
Agents Valérian et Laureline, vous avez moins de 6 heures pour localiser la menace et l'éliminer.
Allez, c'est parti.
L'univers entier est contre nous.
Nous voulons que tous les deux, vous soyez les gardiens de notre futur.
T'es sûre de savoir ce que tu fais ?
Valérian, fais-moi confiance.
Il reste combien de temps ?
Notre destinée est entre vos mains.
C'est moi qui lui ai appris ça.